[Music]
really at the end of the day we're here
for one reason i think we'll be very
active in free agency
cj mosley
the new york jets select
quinn williams it feels amazing to be in
new york watch out for this jets team
they got more players than i think the
public realizes things are on the up and
up
you know we try to figure out all the
time which of the teams in the afc east
other than the patriots are in best
position to challenge for the division
title jets bills maybe dolphins the jets
though chris this offseason a little bit
of an all-in move with the le'veon bell
acquisition they were the only team that
was seriously pursuing him at that
magnitude where they signed him
and hey if the guy plays like he did
before he took a year off they're going
to be happy with what they get out of
le'veon bell the question is will he
still be the same guy that we last saw
two seasons ago yeah that will be the
big question if he is i mean watch out
for this jets team i'm going to echo
kind of something we had in that little
match up there coming out of that is it
i think the jets are you know like the
bills in the afc so maybe the jets are
even a little farther along uh is a very
sneaky good roster i really do i think
this team has got talent uh and a lot of
spots there's only one issue with this
team that i look at and go oh i wish
they had this one position you'd go
they're pretty complete other than that
they don't have a top-tier pass rusher
coming off the edge but still got a lot
of good big people on their defensive
line you know with leonard williams and
now the third pick in the draft quinn
and williams who a lot of people thought
was you know maybe the best player in
the draft but you get cj mosley at
middle linebacker you improve your
offensive line and trade for collegio
semeli from from their oakland raiders
who's getting up there in age but still
one of the better guards in football you
do that you add jameson crowder in the
slot to a sneaky good receiving court as
is mike you know robbie anderson can fly
quincy and nunua i think is kind of a
hybrid tight end big receiver slot guy
who's an awesome football player and i
always look at their tight ends on their
roster and go they got a lot of
potential they got some young studs
there and and chris herndon uh and
jordan legette neal stirling so i look
at the the jets as being one of those
teams with the coaching changes and go
you know watch out for them i guess the
big thing is does gase greg williams
everything
you know cohesive uh on that side
because we've heard stories there but i
do like greg williams as a d coordinator
and adam gases and oc so that that
aspect i really look at the jets is
going in the right direction
yeah i i agree with you and sam darnold
is going to be the key they haven't had
a true franchise quarterback since joe
namath i mean yeah they've had flashes
ken o'brien chad pennington brett favre
for three quarters of a season until his
biceps tendon became partially detached
but if sam darnold can continue along
the track that we saw last year if they
can protect him if le'veon bell can take
some heat off of him set up play action
down the field
this could get very very interesting and
just think the jets were trying to trade
back into round two to get me cole
hardman before the chiefs could get him
could you imagine if they had a weapon
like that they could throw into that mix
but even without him even without him
that this is a team i put them on par
with the bills and i know sometimes you
put the bills a little bit higher but i
think the jets are a team that that
could make things interesting this year
adam gase has coached well against the
patriots he's going to be motivated to
kick the crap out of the dolphins
because they fired him after the 2018
season and some would say it was a
little bit early to pull the plug on a
guy who had taken the team to the
playoffs something that rarely happens
in miami and he's going to be motivated
he's going to be driven he's going to
have a chip on his shoulder every single
day he's got greg williams there running
the defense he's gonna have a chip on
his shoulder i think that thing's been
surgically attached to his shoulder so
this jets team you know they have an
opportunity we talked about the browns
and their schedule and how maybe if they
stumble out of the gates that balloon's
gonna get popped week two monday night
football everybody's on the browns
everybody's on the browns the jets have
a hell of an opportunity to get some
people's attention uh kind of like they
did last year when they beat the lions
week one and then they fell apart but
other than that other than that uh you
know they could make a big splash this
year on a monday night and carry it
through a few more weeks of the season
yeah they could and i think while you're
talking about the schedule and if you're
watching on tv i mean it's it's a brutal
schedule really when you talk about
bills and browns which i you know you
and i are on par there i think we both
think those are two teams to watch out
for but then you got to play the
patriots in week three and in week seven
and then in between that you got the
eagles and the cowboys i mean holy cow
that is not gonna be uh an easy start of
the season or an easy first seven games
for the new york jets they are gonna
have to come out of that somewhere in
the the three and four four and three
range if they wanna have a chance to
make a run of the playoffs when all said
and done but i think a lot of that will
the whole season will be dictated by
that early season and how they handle it
but mike you make a lot of good points
and listen adam gase i'm excited for
what he brings to the new york jets you
know listen i'm not going to put adam
gayson sean payton you know uh sean
mcvay josh mcdaniels category for
offensive coordinators yet but damn he's
that next group down of guys where i go
wow he's an impressive play caller his
teams are always tough you know they
don't they're never fooled or unprepared
and that's what i look forward to with
this new york jets team like you said
le'veon bell his ability to run between
the tackles sam darnold's phenomenal
intermediate thrower really showed
tremendous progress after his injury
last year the last few weeks of the
season and i'm with you mike i mean i
think that the new york jets
if they can go through that early part
of the season like i said where they're
not in too bad of a spot i think they
can be in this playoff conversation come
december
you know gase i think is at that point
where his career is going to go one way
or the other and there's no in between
when you get fired by one team and land
immediately with another if it doesn't
work there yeah chance number three may
be a long time down the road if it ever
even comes you know something about that
schedule that caught my eye when you
consider the nfc east with the two teams
that have established quarterbacks and
the two teams that don't yeah you'd
rather get the giants in washington
early right they get the eagles and
cowboys early they're getting the giants
on washington week 10 and 11. and you
know if daniel jones may be playing then
dwayne haskins will be much better then
than he would be early in the year
that's right
this this is not going to be easy for
the jets maybe they're a year away from
making that run at the top of the
division i i look is anybody gonna make
a run at the top of the division as long
as tom brady and bill belichick are
together no but at least at least we
have to a shred of hope a little shred
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports